después de las explosiones humo pero
también heridos y muertos son el
resultado de los ataques que está
llevando a cabo la guardia
Revolucionaria de Irán contra los que
considera disidentes kurdos en el norte
de Irak esta operación continuará con
nuestra plena determinación hasta que la
amenaza sea efectivamente repelida las
bases de los grupos terroristas sean
desmanteladas y las autoridades de la
región curda asuman sus obligaciones y
responsabilidades los ataques se están
produciendo cerca de hervir y su lai
manilla mediante drones no tripulados
entre los objetivos las sedes de
distintos partidos políticos que abogan
por crear una entidad kurda en Irán algo
a lo que se niega la República islámica
también ha habido quejas desde el
Ministerio de asuntos exteriores de Irak
consideran que es una violación de su
soberanía y llamaron al embajador iraní
para informarle de su rechazo al ataque
desde irán acusan a disidentes kurdos
iraníes armados de estar detrás de las
protestas que vive el país estás
comenzaron tras la muerte de marsa a
mini en custodia policial por llevar el
velo mal puesto el estallido está siendo
especialmente virulento en el noroeste
de Irán fronterizo con el kurdistán
iraquí y donde viven la mayoría de los
10 millones de kurdos iraníes